okay well we normally think of black
holes as forming when stars collapse
under the influence of their own gravity
the pressure that tries to keep them up
isn't enough to stop them from
collapsing in and then they inexorably
fall down into a singularity and form an
event horizon they have a mass of order
at least as a mass of the sun a solar
mass there could be a few more tens of
solar masses and even even the ones in
the center of our galaxy the
supermassive black holes of millions of
solar masses but these are different
these particular ones
could have masses down as small as 10 to
the minus five grams ten to the minus
five grams is it's got it's the planck
mass but it's a probably this the mass
of a neuron also they would they could
have formed extremely early on in the
universe in the period which we would
associate with quantum gravity scales
but they can we can have a range of
masses we could have a mass
that size of a golf ball we could have a
mass a particular interesting one the
mass ranges around 10 to the 15 grams
that's about the size of the mass of
mount everest what is a primary black
hole okay well it's a black hole but uh
it formed very early in the universe
that's kind of where the primordial bit
comes from you don't have to have a star
to form a black hole i think that's the
key thing here what you need is a region
of high density of matter of material
and then you need some big fluctuation
which occurs over a region of this of
space in which you get an increased
amount of matter such that it you've got
so much matter that it falls within what
we would call it schwarzschild radius
and an event horizon can form and you
formed a black hole it didn't need to
come from a collapsing star it can just
be that there was some fluctuation which
arose from something happening in the
early universe which led to this uh
formation what's the conditions here
there's no
stars or anything is there we got like
no particles yeah these could have
formed way before stars form they they
could form some of the best probes we
have of the very early universe the fact
that these these massive objects are
forming so early on and yes it's it's
because there's a primordial super
particles there that could have
coalesced for for some reason some
fluctuation occurred driven by any by
lots of different types of phenomena one
of them is in the inf during a period of
inflation the you you when the universe
expands exponentially fast that you have
fluctuations of the of the energy
density responsible for inflation and
those fluctuations can in regions of the
universe cause these things to form i
suppose in the very early universe
you're thinking of the quarks and the
gluons that around it's you know sub
sub the second time before a second when
you might say the first nuclei form at
the time of nuclear synthesis certainly
way before 300 000 years after the big
bang when you'd think of the first atoms
forming so these are the building blocks
if you like of our universe that that
are moving around in a plasma and then
you you're coalescing these regions
together they could have formed right at
the ear the plank here although you know
you'd be very got to be very careful we
don't really understand the physics of
quantum gravity but they could form from
then on in and associated with different
time scales and as i said the one that's
particularly of interest for us today
from constraining these would have
formed about 10 to the minus 23 seconds
after the big bang this is amazing right
we're we're going to be using
observations today to constrain a
physics event that could have occurred
way before the first second so professor
in this first second we've got the soup
of quarks
a whole bunch of primordial black holes
of various sizes form what happens next
what's happening to the case so this is
where the the really cool stuff comes in
the thing that makes them really
potentially very interesting and it's
thanks to stephen hawking lots of stuff
is thanks to stephen hawking he realized
that black holes don't remain black they
evaporate thermal radiation photons if
you like and as they evaporate they
shrink their mass decreases so quantum
physics is coming in they evaporate
because of quantum mechanics
but what he showed was that the rate at
which a black hole evaporates is
inversely proportional to its mass so a
light black hole evaporates very rapidly
and the associated temperature of this
radiation is very high a massive black
hole therefore evaporates very very
slowly and has an associated very low
temperature so in the early universe
where you have very light black holes 10
to the minus 5 grams a gram 10 to the 17
grams these things are evaporating quite
rapidly and in fact anything below 10 to
the 15 grams the ones that are formed
after 10 to the minus 23 seconds they
have basically all evaporated by today
the fact that they have evaporated
actually places very important
constraints on some of the
models of our universe the the ones that
are evaporating today
uh are had to have a mass of about 10 to
this 15 grams so they're coming to the
end of their life now and they're
emitting photons of
orders of 100 giga electron volts and we
can look for these they're looking for
gamma rays we can look for these objects
in the sky we can go and see are we
finding any of them and the fact we
don't see any of these gamma rays places
constraints on the number of these black
holes that could have been formed at
this scale
and that in turn places constraints on
the its contribution to the overall mass
of the universe so it turns out for a
for a black hole of a mass 10 to the 15
grams
mount everest type black holes they have
to contribute less than a hundredth of a
millionth
of the total mass of our universe energy
density of our universe 10 to the minus
8 of the overall total
and and you can do the same for all
these mass scales by looking at what
they produce and constraining them by
the fact we're not seeing evidence of
them
and in particular in the early universe
right the ones that have evaporated the
ones that have gone well you say well
how on earth can you test for them
they've got well what they'll have done
of course is they've produced radiation
as they went they're very hot they
produce radiation they will have
affected for example the time at which
the first nuclei wanted to form it's
called nuclear synthesis that occurred
about about a second the process began
if you've got lots and lots of very high
energy particles that have been emitted
by these black holes they will delay the
onset of the formation of these of these
nuclei because every time protons and
neutrons try to combine together these
photons will have come in and smack them
apart again and so it would delay that
onset but that's their legacy that's
their legacy but we we have very good
bounds on when this occurred because we
can measure the abundance of these of
these nuclei and that in turn places
very tight constraints on the amount of
primordial black holes that in turn
places very tight constraints on the
models the physics models which led to
those primordial black holes forming and
in fact you can rule out models based on
the fact that you would have predicted
they would have formed so many of these
very small black holes they would have
then injected so much radiation into the
universe that would have delayed the
onset of nuclear synthesis we don't see
that so you work backwards and you've
constrained these models this is how it
works not detecting them actually
sometimes can be quite useful
when the primordial black holes formed
the ones that didn't evaporate yeah they
sort of stayed embedded in the universe
they're all evaporating yeah just slowly
so the massive ones are evaporating
slower than the lighter ones sorry but
the ones that haven't evaporated yeah
yeah
they just sort of stay embedded they're
just like they're just like stuck in
random parts yeah they're there the the
and so for example those that uh have a
mass bigger than 10 to the 15
grams
there's a range of masses for which
these in principles could act as dark
matter candidates because they're
they're massive objects they'd be very
massive objects stuck in and maybe in
the centers of galaxies and there could
be lots of them there and there are
indeed mass ranges i think for example
if they've got a mass range i think it's
10 to the 20 to 10 to the 26 grams we
can't yet rule them out as dogmatic
candidates similarly if they've got
masses in the range of i think it's ten
solar masses to a hundred solar masses
they also can play roles of dogmatic
candidates they're different from your
typical dogmatic candidates which are
subatomic particles that we associated
with super symmetry for example or wimps
but they're still plausible candidates
and yeah they're sitting around and
that's one of the goals is to try and
search for these objects but also
constrain them by looking for decay
products as they evaporate so for all
this talk about what is dark matter and
all these tiny little interesting exotic
particles they could be at the end of
the day they could just be big hulking
ageing old black holes absolutely
we can't rule them out yet yes and and
you know there's a there's there are
also possibilities that we we actually
don't really understand the end point of
a black hole evaporating what actually
happens is it evaporates one result is
that perhaps they form a relic they
evaporate evaporate evaporate down to
around the planck scale and then they
just stop they stop evaporating anymore
and here's my relic and then you've got
all these relics of about the planck
scale
circling around the universe there are
reasons people don't like it to do with
information and storing of information
but
it's not ruled out as totally ruled out
as a as a model
i'm picturing all these big cold shot
puts floating exactly it's wonderful and
and then i mean they can you can go a
bit further i mean you can because they
could form all these different epochs
right due to these fluctuations those
that correspond to a fluctuation at
around a second the corresponding mass
of those black holes would be ten to the
five solar masses well that happens to
be the the type of mass scale that you
find in the
centers of galaxies right these are the
supermassive black hole scales a bit
bigger one possibility is that the
progenitors of these supermassive black
holes are in fact
primordial black holes formed a second
after the universe began that then can
begin to accumulate matter around them
that as far as i know hasn't been ruled
out that's still a possibility it should
be raining down that's the radiation
from these things it depends upon the
the number of them out there right so um
and so what this is doing is placing
tighter and tighter constraints on the
allowed number and i told you what the
current bound is the current bound is
their contribution to the overall energy
budget has to be less than 10 to the
minus eight it still sounds like it
could be reasonable radiation is ten to
the minus four or so today mata called
that matter is about point three so
these have to be negligible the reason
they have to be negligible is precisely
what you say it hasn't been seen yet how
long of not saying them how much more
does that moose have to tighten before
you say hang on maybe these things just
aren't there oh that's a really good
question i i think if
for you to be able to say that
you would have to somehow rule out the
mechanism by which they could form you
would have to demonstrate that that
mechanism isn't physically plausible or
has been ruled out for some other reason
if you can't rule out that mechanism
then there's no reason why they
shouldn't form
what what the bounds are telling you is
that it that mechanism
just obviously wasn't very efficient at
forming them in the earliness or didn't
occur very often
ultimately it might be telling us
something quite fundamental about our
theories if we don't see any if we don't
see any evidence of primordial black
holes that indeed is going to be telling
us something quite important about the
very early universe and about the type
of physics that went on there that we
that we just haven't yet picked up on so
the physics of nuclear synthesis is
really quite well established the the
the process by which the protons and
neutrons begin to combine and the rate
at which they begin to combine is is
quite well instantly it just requires an
understanding of nuclear physics and
local
thermodynamics in in regions the the
input of the black holes in this sense
is that it changes the the if you like
the the temperature of the radiation
that's around it determines the time
scale at which nuclear synthesis should
occur i agree completely that the
physics of how the black holes form and
the physics of how many form
is based on various assumptions about
our understanding of how regions
collapse how they break off from the
expanding universe and collapse down to
form these objects and then the number
of density of these objects that form
that depends upon some input parameter
about the distribution of these of these
black holes that is that's theoretical
input that is either intuitive or
ideally would come from some underlying
theory but there's always assumptions
made these are models we understand our
universe as a model we're always testing
the model and the idea is that we we
test it till it breaks and then we see
how what we have to change in the model
to make it compatible again with
observations it's important that the
black holes that are evaporating right
now that are coming to the end of their
life and
they are mountain mass black holes they
formed about 10 to the minus 23 seconds
after the big bang
those that formed a second after the big
bang are already ten to the five solar
masses
those that formed even later after the
you know are correspondingly bigger and
yeah they're proper black holes they're
they're they're evaporating the ones
that are evaporating you know that are
10 to the five solar mass black holes
are evaporating very very slowly they're
very got a very low temperature so
they're incredibly difficult to detect
in fact you know hawking would
undoubtedly win the nobel prize if they
could directly detect hawking radiation
but the problem is hawking radiation
coming from these massive black holes is
10 to the minus eight kelvin or so it
was incredibly
low couldn't they ever created more
masses yes yes oh wow well done yes so
one possibility with black holes is that
they form and then we know they
evaporate but they also accrete of
course we know they accrete and so
indeed it's a it's a mechanism by which
some black holes could actually grow so
we're talking we're ballpark figures
here right that's what i'm using you're
quite right there's classes of black
holes that would have formed and then
depending on the vicinity that the stuff
that was around them they would have
started accreting faster than it would
be evaporating but in terms of ballpark
figures as to the time scale that a
given mass black hole would evaporate on
ones evaporating today correspond to the
10 to 15 gram black holes if it created
many many more grams of matter they'll
evaporate correspondingly later on the
probability of them forming now is
extremely rare because we don't have
those supernovas that's right that's
right it would take a ginormous
fluctuation to to cause it whereas and
the density basically has dropped so
much i think that's the key thing that
as you say we don't have that soup the
density of this soup is so so low now
that you would you know you'd have to
have a massive bucket of putting it all
back together whereas in the early
universe the density is much much higher
and it's easier to flick them to make
one oh yeah they were just popping up
everywhere yeah yeah there is a possible
candidate for a sighting of primordial
black holes you mentioned
so
of course this is an early early work
but the amazing discovery by the ligo
team of the coalescing black holes these
black holes have masses of around 30
solar masses and it's actually quite
difficult to figure out a mechanism by
which you form 30 solar mass black holes
never mind and then having them in pairs
how come they're formed in pairs that
are circling one another so it has led
to a few papers suggesting actually
maybe these are the seeds of these
primordial black holes which would have
formed suitably early in the universe
you can then get a 30 solar mass black
holes but once again it's what's
interesting you know the way science
works the the once this discovery was
announced and it surprised everybody
within a few weeks the first sets of
papers came out
claiming this but even but you know and
ann green here my colleague here at
nottingham was able to show that
actually it's going to be very difficult
to have this result explained in terms
of these primordial black holes because
of constraints that emerge from looking
at the decay products of black holes and
that constrains the density that you're
going to get of them it doesn't mean
they're not there and it doesn't yet
mean it it's not this mechanism and it's
a very intriguing mechanism i think but
that's the way science works you come
out with an idea then you test the idea
against observations
a black hole that could range from
millions to trillions times the mass of
our sun
and so
it's important to consider this black
hole even though physically compared to
the size of the galaxy it's very very
small